you can tell people who've grown up with
this when they say plantain as opposed
to the incorrect pronunciation it's a
plantain I don't know to be clear we
don't know what that is I might go ahead
and I'm representing Trinidad
hi I'm Mika and I'm representing Jamaica
I'm Anthony I'm from South Llano
Trinidad Tobago
I'm Kat I'm from Kingston Jamaica so I
was born in Trinidad I stayed there for
two and a half years and I moved to
Brooklyn and that's where I grew up I
was born in Florida United States and I
moved to Jamaica and I was young and
I've been back and forth ever since I
actually moved from Trinidad in 2004 I
grew up in all my life in Kingston and
just traveled a bunch because I lost a
family like in Florida's most Jamaicans
do as far as you're making snacks they
are very similar
they're pretty interchangeable you know
you have them growing up when you're in
high school there are some that I
haven't had those I'm excited to see
what this is about
yeah I'm excited to try some of these
snacks drinks are oh so it was like you
know Christmas ginger beer is also
similar beverage
so I just got this national hmm this is
very exciting because it's kind of a
staple in Jamaican household okay the
flavors are kind of very homey very
familiar the kind of the flavors that
your mom cooks with yeah the smells that
you smell at home it's kind of a warm
hug of a snack okay I'm excited about
that I never had one before smells like
my childhood like definitely quick Oh
spicy
yeah like nutmeg all right yeah it's
kind of like a dessert button you know
what people eat it like I mean like I
remember growing up if you never have a
lot of lunch money I give you a bone and
cheese and it's like very filling so we
have some fried plantains here this is
classic I'm sure you know for and yeah
Caribbean oh you know literally it's
mandatory exactly this to me reminds me
of Sunday lunch you know water crystal
callaloo rice stew chicken every Sunday
Nina this one is looking all right oh
yeah
okay okay enjoy you are the same Jamaica
full of joy uh hmm that's good that's a
good reaction well I didn't know what to
expect but this is good right the
texture mm-hmm the bun is good it really
reminds me of a sweet bun that we used
to make in Trinidad ascension that we
have something called sweet bread it's
kind of similar they use like raisins
and fruit so it has a similar texture
similar it tastes a little cool yeah
oh no we might have no this normally eat
planted with like
by itself for breakfast for lunch for
dinner
mm-hmm mm-hmm it's like around the clock
can count on planting to be there for
you planted tree so like this wouldn't
be my choice of 200 plantain
why not because it's not ripe enough for
me I would leave it alone like fine my
extra week yeah I make it good but like
the skin get blocka and then add fried
okay so I have this weird thing where I
tend to not combine sweet with savory so
mmm
while everyone I know that everyone
needs plantain all the time but I do not
mmm but I also respect and appreciate
the tradition yeah and that's why I'm
eating it right now if you can say
you're not gonna come on here has a
Jamaican not eat Blanton I respect it in
front of me I have some Cameron well I'm
so excited I love anything tamarind I
like bittersweet flavors this is a
classic I'm very excited and I'm excited
for you to try what's interesting about
which I cage of tamarind balls is anyway
I have the coconut drops
I don't eat coconut drops I drink
coconut water but I don't really consume
yeah I think it's like to chew it for me
all right
so is that God texting someone and you
thing about these is that nothing about
this looks like a drop so it does its
thing they're always kind of
homemade-looking mm-hmm and I just see
them you know in gas stations Pharmacy
yeah like you never see them
mass-produced yes I kind of in this way
yeah all right I love time removes let
me go open eyedrops
hmm now is this spicy because some of
them you can have them like they put
like you know a hint of like heat in it
no spice at all mmm in terms of heat mmm
I didn't know that came spicy food
that's interesting those are good but
it's super sweet and kind of like tacky
yeah tricky thing is though what to do
with the pits when you're done yeah
right so I got three seeds in one
sometimes you don't get any seeds in
them that one had three and it's just
sugar and Tamron and it's really good I
suggest it and just box one of these
she'll under these one time like this as
a kid but it's really good delicious
all right so we've got to get into these
drops here oh okay so it does remind me
of sugar cane sugar cake is like a snack
and Trinity we have it it's a coconut is
shredded but it's usually in like a
circular like fall it's pretty sweet
crunching it reminds me of got sugar
kick like in school when we were growing
up they would have with the shops
outside our law school and just
something to munch on to led oh nice
when the different cultures have
different names for the same thing so
this here we have the caramel biscuits
this I remember again we used to go to
the market a lot and this was the only
thing that my stepfather ever wanted he
was like all right give me a give me a
caramel give me two packs if you want
they usually come in this this four pack
size it's really good like a nice
chocolate-covered wafer basically I've
never had this before and I'm really
excited because I do enjoy away from me
also with caramel and that's definitely
a plus
so I'm definitely excited about trying
this sorry I have candied sorry oh sorry
laser fluid at
we using Jamaica to make a holiday drink
called sorry
usually the add ginger or Rome like
white rum red Rome if you want and I've
never actually seen this or had this I
don't know if my Jamaican cars going get
revoke but I've never seen this before
have you ever seen Paco Candida and it
says a better snack yeah we're gonna be
drinking it you know so the the version
I know if it is the drink is a beverage
I don't know it like this so oh they are
individually wrap okay this is cute yeah
oh okay
I really like you can tell that when
they were making it I'm gonna be honest
and say I think that these might be a
bit stale what do you think I think they
tend to be good like this mm-hmm oh no
no it's fine it's fine because I didn't
get that crunch then at least yeah yeah
for the you know wafer part so I wasn't
sure but okay
I trust you oh okay I carry that to work
on that cut through that caramel I would
I would prefer a little more wafer than
Carmen
it's like um is that not twigs it's like
cake cut interesting this was Scotland
moaning ooh well I didn't know that I
thought this was direct from China the
more you know I never noticed you know
we mentioned Scotland I never noticed
that it was like a white boy on the on
the packaging oh we just straight-up
took scotland snack and made it our own
I mean exactly sorry
Roman this sorry yeah Cheers
Jews less up yeah that's good
I like it I would drink this daily like
oh people in LA drink kombucha this is
like Jamaica kombucha
that's good this is good I like it it
has that nice slight bite of ginger at
the end okay also the color it's nice
robust red mm-hmm him I'm inspired I
think about to go home thanks I'm sorry
you know was this place tender greens
actually I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah but they call it how my career yeah
hibiscus hibiscus yeah you know I just
figured out that that's what it was is
hell yeah yeah yeah me I've been to
Mexico a couple of times they caught how
my god which is really cute because yeah
you know ya need to make so this was
really fun I enjoyed the opportunity to
try some Jamaican snacks and to relive
some Trini snacks I hope it's a my
favorite would be the sorrow oh I don't
know it's tie between the bun in the
sorrow because those were on point
definitely have tight race yeah my
favorite the bun was really good yeah it
was very fluffy and yes airy I really
like that about it mm-hmm great job fun
makers I would say my favorite thing as
a Tamron ball and I mean it's that close
tie with the Tamron ball and the bun
what about you wanna say my favorite was
actually bun the body yeah we might have
sweet bun going up internet dog and
startup yeah it's nice to reminisce and
it is blackening these slacks
especially you know the brings back
memories no childhood memories and I
would friends but yeah it's great I
enjoyed that yeah
[Music]
you